foreign
[Music]
and led POI friends I'm not gonna lie
this is the mashup that I have been
waiting for Drex here from drexfactor
POI sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am coming at
you with a review of these led fabric
soft POI or as they're called Neo socks
that are a collaboration between neopoi
and sock POI but before we dive in I
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyrotera light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lei machinski and Becca
becklenen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so I have made absolutely no secret of
my love of the fabric POI that Kachi
stock anova's online shop called sock
boy produce they're eye-catching they're
really really simple in terms of
Hardware they have a great weight and
quite frankly they just look beautiful
on video so I was super excited to
discover that they'd entered into a deal
with LED POI company neopoi to produce
an LED version of those sock POI that I
knew and loved and well once I saw them
I was super duper eager to get my hands
on a set as usual I have my review
rubric that we'll be going through that
will include talking about the features
of these POI as well as the ease of use
the durability the brightness the
battery life some personal thoughts and
of course finally the price
all right so let's start things off by
talking about features
now the theory of course Behind These is
that just like when you're using sock
POI in your daytime practice and they
have a wonderful visual profile we're
trying to make the same thing happen
with LED POI so we're using the LED
assemblies inside of these to light up
the entire sock at night these are
pretty much identical to the other sock
POI that you'll find in katyistaka
Nova's shop the one big difference of
course is that instead of having the
solid balls that are dropped into the
ends that get turned into handles these
make use of the neopoi handles that if I
remember from my review of neopoy's
contact POI I at one point said these
really ought to be a standalone product
and it's really cool to see them used in
that regard inside the heads rather than
using the bean bags that we are used to
seeing from katya's sock Point instead
we have these interesting little
assemblies where the housing is 3D
printed but the inside is the capsule
that we've seen before from neopoi uh
mainly in their LED contact POI so if
you're familiar with those capsules
already it's literally just the exact
same Hardware which also means that
these get turned on and the modes
changed using a single button interface
right here at the very very end you hold
on for just a minute to get it to turn
on you can navigate with a single button
press between a bunch of different modes
and you can get to a different page of
modes by holding down the button until
you see that Green Flash and once again
you can just use a single button to page
through I want to say it is 32 modes
it's basically four Banks of eight
different modes and of course to turn it
back off you just hold down the button
until it flashes out like that to
recharge the LED capsules you have to
remove the cap here on the end of this
assembly and that gets you access to a
little micro USB slot that you can plug
into the wall and also it gives you
direct access to the button that is used
to turn on and to switch through all the
different modes for these
all right now let's talk ease of use
so as many of you know I have a test for
any set of LED POI that I come across
namely how fast can I get them turned on
and into a mode that is basically usable
for me without knowing anything about
how they are programmed and with these
POI I'm happy to report that getting
them turned on and into a mode that I
like pretty easy uh no must no fuss
there I will say that the default mode
that they turn onto is one that is kind
of a shuffle that moves between a bunch
of different modes and at first it seems
like it's going to be solid white mode
and then it turns out not to be that was
a little confusing but aside from that
yeah getting these turned on and into a
mode that I like not that difficult I
will say though that for accessing other
modes and mode Banks the whole idea of
holding down the button to get between
different mode Banks is one that isn't
super intuitive based upon some of the
other LED POI that I've used in my time
so that I definitely needed some help
with in the manual but like that's my
only quibble here and I do have to say
one thing I really like about out how
this design is set up is that you do
have the single button interface that
works through the sock here on the end
so you can switch modes very very easily
without say like having to remove the
assembly to do it things like that are
super helpful and make these a lot
easier to use there is one flip side to
that and that is just that in order to
recharge the LED unit you actually have
to physically remove it from the sock
POI which takes a little bit of jamming
to do it's not the worst but I wish
there was a more intuitive and easy way
to charge them without having to remove
the entire unit
I honestly can't think of how that would
be done I think that's just kind of
baked into the form factor here but yeah
it's it's just a little note there
all right now let's talk durability
so I noted this in my review of neopoy's
LED contact POI a few years ago but uh
basically all the components that they
use in their POI are 3D printed and so
there's always going to be a point of
weakness between the layers that get set
down in 3D printing that said these
assemblies are the most flexible and
solid 3D printed assemblies I think I
have seen yet so I'm not super worried
about their potential for braking in the
future if for no other reason then they
do get a little bit of padding from the
sock itself the one and only thing I'll
point out here which ironically enough
has nothing to do with the LEDs
whatsoever themselves has to do with the
socks is that these beautiful
plain white socks that the light filters
through also pick up stains like if you
can see right here I've already managed
to brush both of these POI through the
grass and picked up a couple grass
stains and
um because the LED handles are
physically attached to them I can't like
run these uh the the fabric part of the
POI through the wash so I'd have to hand
wash them
and you know again I think that's just
kind of baked into the design of these I
don't know that there's any way to like
stain treat the socks themselves but
that's something to keep in mind as you
use them if you if they pick up stain
they're going to be pretty hard to get
out
all right now let's talk brightness
so straight up the assemblies in these
are super bright it was something that I
really liked about the neopoi LED
contact POI which used the same sets of
lights and it's a great feature of these
Neo socks POI as well
you have no worries about them being
bright enough everybody's going to be
able to see you this is all the more
important of course because with these
LEDs they do have to light up the entire
sock I mean the whole point of this
after all is to eliminate the entirety
of that sock but they do a pretty good
job of it I have to say
so what about battery life
so some of y'all may remember but this
was actually one of the major things
that I dinged the neopoi sets on before
is just uh in exchange for getting that
great brightness we lose a lot of
battery life
um when you turn them on the plain white
mode and just leave it there solid white
you wind up with about two and a half
hours worth of battery life
um if you light it up in Rainbow fade
mode you wind up with closer to three
hours of battery life now that said it's
been a couple years since I did that
battery test and I didn't have a chance
to run it again on these I don't know if
they've changed anything about their
design or the type of batteries they're
using here so I'm just repeating that
data because I'm pretty sure these are
the exact same lights but if I'm wrong
in that regard look to the comments of
this video to see if I post a retraction
or an update to that
so now let's talk some personal thoughts
so real talk I love katya's sock POI and
the biggest thing that I wanted out of
these was to get the feel and the look
of her sock POI but have them work after
dark and I'm pleased to report that
these absolutely do that in Spades my
biggest concern with these honestly is
that one of the things that I really
like about the unlit sock POI is they're
super portable they basically Crush down
to a really small size and I can carry
them around in my shoulder bag wherever
I go I decided to try out an experiment
and for the past few weeks I have been
carrying these around instead of the
classic sock POI just to see if I notice
them taking up a lot more room in my bag
and how comfortable that is and in all
honesty even though the LED assemblies
in these socks take up more room than
the bean bags that are normally in the
ends of these sock POI that didn't make
a huge difference in terms of the amount
of space that they take up in my bag
whether it's daytime or nighttime these
wound up being just just about as
portable an option as the classic sock
POI which is great I will also say these
unexpectedly wound up solving one of my
few quibbles with katya's sock boy which
is that I think that her handles aren't
heavy enough and it's not easy enough to
be able to stick other handle options on
there so so the neopoi handles which I
have always loved uh now have completely
fixed that problem with the handle
weight as well as the profile of them
these feel fantastic they feel much
closer to say contact POI in terms of
the grip that they have and the weight
distribution they have so I'm giving an
A plus for that now all that said there
were three things that stuck out to me
as I was testing these out that I think
are possible areas for improvement so
number one even though these led
capsules are super bright and illuminate
most of the socks they don't usually get
all the way to the ends of the socks one
of the reasons that the handles are so
handy eh pun intended is that the
lighting kind of cuts off by right about
here I don't know if there is another
way to angle the LED capsules so more
the illumination is pointed down rather
than out but there was something that
did jump out to me as I was watching
video of these is that the light
distribution through the socks did kind
of cut off at a certain point the second
thing ironically enough even though I
love having the button interface on the
end is that the buttons actually a
little too easy to press I found myself
several times as I was spinning these if
I got up to speed the centrifugal force
that would happen pushing the capsules
outward into the sock would frequently
accidentally result in button presses
that were not intentional that is the
resistance of the sock itself pushing
against the capsule would frequently
result in button presses that were not
meant to happen it's really not that
huge deal and to be perfectly Frank with
you I could easily solve that by just
removing the 3D printed element that
covers the button and the micro USB port
it means it'd be kind of a little bit
more of a pain in the butt to actually
dig in there and hit the button and you
know be confident that I was hitting it
uh but yeah at the same time I'd like
not to have to modify them to keep from
accidentally doing button presses you
know okay so finally this is admittedly
a kind of shallow and superficial thing
to like have a concern about but like
when you insert the capsules into these
we've got a little thing where in the
capsule itself
extends uh past the point where the
scene meets and you wind up with this
weird little kind of uh puff that
happens outward with the seam that's
impossible to get rid of completely
um it's definitely not the end of the
world and it's one of those things that
like there's definitely some element of
like neurodivergent brain that's just
looking at that and it's like I wish I
could correct that
um but yeah I just wish that there was a
way to make that seam disappear entirely
so that when the capsule was in there it
would just be like totally seamless and
like a normal looking sock rather than
having that little bit that puffed out I
don't know it's it's a little thing but
hey so if you'd like to grab a set of
these for yourself the Neo socks that is
the LED fabric sock POI from neopoi and
sock POI you can grab a set of them for
150 a pair without the LED handles
they're 250 dollars a pair with the LED
handles and you can do that over at
sockpoi.store that is the new storefront
for katya's uh company also I'm really
pleased to announce that uh I am
sponsored by sock POI now we've been
trying to make this happen now for quite
some time and so if you're watching this
video and you'd like to get a discount
on a set of these you can use my promo
code drexfactor over at
sockpoi.store to go ahead and get
yourself a pair of these at a little bit
of a discount also it helps out the
channel so everybody wins thanks so much
to Katya and the wonderful folks over at
sock POI for finally connecting the dots
on that and allowing me to be sponsored
by a company whose products I have loved
for years now did you get anything out
of this video please leave a like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find it and of course to
help my channel grow
[Music]
thank you
this video would not be possible or not
for the kind support of all of these
lovely people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description helps make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very
generous support if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there you
can get access to a whole host of really
awesome rewards and even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spending and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out some of my other
reviews of LED props I will go ahead and
leave a link to a playlist of them down
in the description as well as up here on
screen if you are watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here based
upon your past viewing habits so maybe
give that a look as well thanks so much
for watching make sure to get out and
flow today and I'll see you with a new
video real soon
peace